I love the rendition of suspicious mind
that's beautiful oh you heard all that I
just spin out of control we're all alone
it was quite inspiring I must say yeah
well here we go again yes love and stir
us can win uh-huh yeah where have you
been this show is fantastic let's just
go right into it what we love about the
show is the fact that you don't
sugarcoat the fact that parents we are
not perfect what do you guys think our
parents can learn from man with a plan
uh well from my character I hope they
don't learn anything I hope they learn a
lot from Liza's character because she's
good pair no he's a good parent - it's
just she it's done a learning curve
right now hey spending more time with
the kids than he ever has before
so he's kind of getting a full
understanding of what that really means
yeah and Matt you have a 12 year old
girl what's one parenting fail you not
only own up to and what's a parenting
wind that you're very proud of
uh I've become a pretty good cook
okay so she eats my cooking which is
which is a plus yeah cuz you gotta feed
them yeah but not after midnight
oh no that's gremlins sorry yeah and a
parenting fail is uh what's a parenting
fail that I have Butterfinger cetera no
I don't drop her okay that's kind of
screwed she's getting big though that's
probably coming yeah I don't know well I
can't think of any oh great as long as
you're chief ebinger
probably pretty good Lisa you might have
known each other for 20 years that's
longer than most marriages did that help
with creating that on-screen chemistry
as a married couple
well I sure I mean I think the fact that
we already had kind of a built in a
friendship and familiarity helped to
make Adam and Andy you know more
believable as people who have been
together for a long time nice and Matt's
what's one thing that you do that
embarrasses your daughter most would you
say
uh that's I think the better way to
phrase that question what's one thing I
do that doesn't embarrass you yes nah
you know daddies and daddies she's at
that age now words don't stand so close
to me and no I'm not I don't want to
give you a kiss goodbye no you can't hug
me and that kind of stuff which is uh
heartbreaking yes
if you're watching
what are you doing in Canada
haha
you
alright Matt of course so me
move your fans to this day our friends
obsessive
if your daughter has watched friend
and what did she think of Joey
you know she's 12 she hasn't really she
knows about it but she hasn't really
nobody I would imagine in the next few
years
she might she might
watching it more but
but
this is the first time when we did the
part of it
this is the first time she's actually
come and watch me work
so because
episodes I was doing was a little too
amateur for her little ears
right she's seen friend
as never she wasn't alive when we were
taping it so this is all new for her